لقد كان كارل حقًا ، بصراحة ،
أعتقد أن مؤتمرًا صحفيًا لـ 6000 في
ليفربول وكنت جزءًا كبيرًا من 5999 في
مقاعد مختلفة بشكل واضح ، لكنك كنت
دائمًا هناك إذا كنت تريد الركوب أو
أي شيء آخر أو اليوم لا تركب اليوم
سجل فقط ولكن  هيا الآن يجب أن
أخبرك مرة أخرى عن قصة المال أو
يجب أن أرويها مرة أخرى
لماذا يمكن أن يكون السبب وراء
امتلاكنا للمال مثل الجنون ولكننا لا
نشتري اللاعبين حتى عندما يكونون متاحين
هذا ما  أنت تفكر بي بعد
كل السنوات
التي أشتريها ، تسأل سؤالًا حيث
تكمن الإجابة على الطاولة وأنا
لا أفهم حقًا أنني لا
أفهم حقًا أنك تقف هنا من أجل
قيادتك هنا ، لا أعرف كيف  لقد أتيت إلى
هنا والآن أقف هنا وهذا
هو السؤال كيف تعرف
الإجابة وإذا كنت سأجيب الآن أجلس هنا لا لا ،
لدينا أموال في البنك على
نطاق واسع لا أعرف ماذا أفعل
ولكن أم اللاعبون بالخارج  هناك
لا تعلمون لا أعلم أننا لا نفعل ذلك